The polls tell us that Americans do not want
the Supreme Court to overturn its 1973 Roe
v. Wade ruling on abortion.
In a Gallup question from July, 64 percent,
did not want the decision overturned.
New polls from Fox News and the Kaiser Family
Foundation produced similar results.
That said, most Americans believe that abortion
should be legal only under certain circumstances,
and they are willing to put considerable restrictions
on the procedure.
In Gallup’s polling on the issue, for example,
around 60 percent say it should be possible
for a woman to obtain a legal abortion in the first three months of a pregnancy.
That drops sharply to around 30 percent when
people are asked about abortions in the second
trimester, and only around 10 percent when
pollsters ask about the third trimester.
In Gallup’s latest poll from May this year,
48 percent of people said they considered
themselves to be pro-life, and an identical
48 percent said they were pro-choice.
The split reflects Americans’ beliefs in
the sanctity of life and the importance of
individual choice.
Do you think roe v. Wade should be overturned? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.